taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two foods gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking welcome to a very
special edition of taste buds doing
something a little bit different here
today
breaking ground today we are going to go
with a battle amongst utensils
instead of foods themselves this was
suggested to us by a fan
i believe i saw it in the comments it
stuck stuck with me and uh we we
we mentioned it usually right before we
start an episode we go what are we gonna
do you know we just riff everything and
and uh i said this would be funny and we
were both cracked up we said let's just
do it let's do it
yeah we might move this podcast after
we're done with all the foods you might
go into other other as we mentioned that
at the time yeah yeah this is still food
related to me though this is very
in the in the mix fork versus spoon
um we didn't know who should take which
we didn't know who would get creamed we
didn't know what was what
so we're also doing something new for
the first time in the episode
we do not have our sides picked we're
picking
well i don't want to all right here's
the thing i don't want to say who we
kind of both thought might win
okay right but we did we both thought
that one was a little favorable to the
other
and we both like a lot of times when we
like the same thing or we want to do the
same thing
we'll either not do it or we'll we'll
pick
something else like like how we don't do
uh we didn't do uh let's say
captain crunchberries we just two other
series because we both agree on the
number one
right so instead this time we said well
let's pick cold
out of a hat the utensil that we'll
argue for because we both think we can
make a case for either
depending right so we are going to pick
which team we will represent out of the
hat right now
that pimp is providing for us
so yeah you're getting that on camera so
you're yeah i'm going to close my eyes
why are you so disappointed it's the
ultimate utensil
i did a little research i did a little
research the spoon was invented before
anything
cavemen used it the fork was invented to
try to improve the spoon
listen which is my opening argument
[Music]
[Laughter]
i love a spoon i love a spoon i love a
spoon and i gotta be honest
i love them my disappointment is not
about cheers
pimp we're all drinking little moscow
meals today
my disappointment is not in my
preference
my disappointment is in what i think
will win
uh according to popular vote we truly
truly we have no clue
we don't have any clue how could we
right i will start off by saying both
have their own purposes and we just we
both thought though that fork might be
the
favorite and so we we to be fair we
would we would choose out of a hat
i will say that when we first discussed
doing this
i said i think i would go with spoon and
you said why
and i said because i feel like you can
eat more fork foods
with a spoon than you can spoon foods
with a fork
so you can't eat soup with a fork
i guess you could eat ice cream with a
fork if you had to
um but i feel like you
with the right spoon i could
i mean people say well what about
spaghetti you need a fork i could cut up
spaghetti with a spoon and scoop it up
that's ambitious you could do it
it's ambitious i could cut meatballs up
with a spoon i could cut sausage with a
spoon and eat it if i had to
uh steak you'd probably have a problem
certain chickens you could you could get
through it
uh certain fish you can get through it
uh i don't know that you could say the
same for spoon foods with a fork
you couldn't you can't eat soup with a
fork you just can't you can't do it you
could eat some of the things
out of the soup but you couldn't do it
so if i was stranded on a desert island
and i had a choice for one utensil
for the rest of my meals i'd probably
have to pick spoon and in fact i think
i'd even pick
knife over fork never mind tonight for
versatility
why why you why are you abandoning the
spoon you're saying i'm just saying
i'm not abandoning anything but you're
already throwing in the knife
in fact i'm watching you i'm watching
you think your way through this and try
to convince
yourself that the spoon is this much
when i use a spork even
i'm using it as a spoon spork is an
abomination
but my point was supposed to be the best
of both worlds it sort of it should have
took
over the industry and yet sporks are
rare and hard to be found
maybe but no one else the point is no
that's the only place i catch them
but no part of that spork is being used
for a fork it's still being used as
well let's be honest the prongs on the
end of a spork are just lackluster
yes or no yeah right yeah yeah now
today you were in traffic coming here
and i knew that we were doing
fork and spoon and
so what i did was i made i made a column
i made pros and cons of forks and pros
and cons for spoons
okay so i have i am also coming today a
little prepared with some thoughts
in place but i will not read you the
counter points
i'm not going to read the negatives and
of the fork and the positives of the
spoon right now okay from my notes
because i'm not trying to help you win
anything
especially because i don't know what
order these are going to necessarily air
in but
never mind okay all right so what's your
point what are you getting at
i'm just letting you know that when
you're ready i have some thoughts jotted
down that i could start to peruse
i'm ready whenever you are
i disagree with your take i think that
you could eat anything with a fork that
you can with a spoon i think this
surface area
would you eat soup with this fork well
let me finish
for the most part i think the surface
area past the prongs
that third of the fork that has a little
bit of like
surface area i think as long as you're
dunking and you're putting back to your
mouth
you might not be getting an abundance of
liquid but you're still going to get
soup
liquid on that part your come on but my
major that's not the major okay
the major point is i spear anything the
fork will take and i sip right out of
the bowl
for the broth well but that's not the
argument the argument is is which is the
more versatile you tend to correct
right and i don't know what to eat
you have a better chance at cutting a
steak
with just a spoon than you do with just
a fork
because a spoon allows you for sharp
edges
potentially sharp edges and
a wider point to try to get down into
that thing and start an incision
you got the same curve on the fork you
could never find that no no
the fork's four prongs yeah because
cause that's because if you have a snake
you have a steak in front of you with a
fork and a spoon and no knife
you're picking up the spoon to cut the
steak i'm saying i would argue that you
could use that spoon to your advantage
better uh no one does that everybody if
you're not picking up a knife
you're only hoping his fork to cut his
side and
and it ain't happening with a steak you
need to get a you need to get a
incision in this thing if i'm not
picking up a knife i'm cutting my steak
with a fork
i'm not going for the spoon that's not
what i've cut steaks with forks my whole
life
i have it especially as a tender i'm
sorry a lot of fillets
a lot of fillets eating with spoons and
cutlery correlates with faster eating
that has been linked with blood sugar
imbalances in the body
how so is it bad to eat with a spoon
let's take you through first of all
like i said the fork came after the
spoon because it was made as an
improvement to the spoon
okay uh as long as your ice cream is not
melting you got it with a fork
good luck with a spoon eating a steak
good luck with a spoon in the center i'm
not cutting a fork
you're not cutting a steak with a fork i
got news for you there's no way in hell
i'll do it right in front of you what do
you mean i'm not
i have you and i will i'm talking a
london broil i'm talking a steak you got
to cut into i'm not talking something
that's
like a speech a dull circle is going to
cut through
you got another chance and with a fork
don't know about that but you get a
better chance for anything i'll put them
i can make an initial incision with a
spoon
i can make an initial incision with the
problem so you're making four holes i
can turn
sideways now yeah because i get the the
prongs i get them into the meat right
right
i get him into the meat ready i get him
into the meat and then i turn
and what the prongs are doing they're
coming up through the meat and then
that's not how it works that doesn't
work like that i i mean that is
specifically how
that's not at all how it works what will
happen basically how it works
that's not how it works how was it work
you got a piece of meat downstairs
cooked we'll put it to the test right
now
i'm serious i i mean odds are no
but i could go look here's a guy eating
this steak with a spoon
on the internet yeah but you i could put
eat a steak with a fork too oh i mean
that's look
the steak is the most beautiful tender
he's touching it and it's falling
my point is is you can get you have you
don't think what he's doing with that
spoon
i could do with a fork no i don't fell
apart like i don't
i don't you've got rounded you've got
angular edges on that spoon that is
allowing you to get an initial incision
in
you don't have that one salesman you
don't have that with a fork
fork most versatile utensil that exists
can cut scoop and spear
can be used as a weapon true
a larger variety of foods can be
physically eaten with a spoon
says who the person who wrote that
article i'm here to tell you no okay
if i can only choose one i choose a fork
no matter what food is in front of me if
i can only choose one for the rest of my
life
i'm gonna choose a fork a fork is more
versatile and i feel like it'll help me
warm
if i if if they said one utensil is
going to be wiped out of existence
wiped out of circulation what would
everyone vote for i think more people
would vote for the fork the fork like i
said anything
anything there's a bowl that melts any
liquid i can drink out of
the bowl sauce tomato sauce whatever i
can scoop that with a fork
the only thing you're talking about is
really liquid but i don't need a
i don't need a spoon to finish my soup i
don't need a spoon
to finish my ice cream you cannot scoop
tomato sauce with a fork
certain kinds of tomato sauce you could
get with the food it still will get on
the fork where
i'm not gonna get the abundance of scoop
that i'm getting with the spoon but if i
go like this in sauce and put it up to
my mouth with a fork
i'm tasting and eating sauce okay but
you can't you can't
basically you can't eat a steak with a
spoon and he's doing a salad
he's eating a steak that fell apart
that's like saying i can eat that's like
saying i can eat uh soup with a
paintbrush
it's like come on no it's not it's
someone eating soup with a fork
let me see it i want to see something
around i want to see it i want to see it
i mean look at that he's eaten just as
much is this asmr jose
by the way you know what he's eating
campbell's cold cream of tomato soup
that's congealed from a can that he just
doesn't exactly
that's not congealed yes it is not
congealed
that's cold soup he put into a bowl yeah
and it stays on the fork
because it's thick enough to not fall it
would stay on a toothpick it's not a way
you're gonna eat the whole bowl of soup
i can even manage cereal or ice cream
and drink the rest from the bowl
can you eat salad with a fork with a
spoon no
certain salads you could you can eat
mostly all foods with a fork
okay what about you said you would eat
pasta with a spoon
cut it up with a spoon you can still
catch liquid on the fork on the
non-prong surface area of the fork
i could catch i could catch what did you
say i couldn't eat with a spoon just now
salad i could catch salad on this bone
you don't think i'm going to get any of
the salad this is my point oh that's
going to be an abomination you're trying
to always eating this trying to scoop it
up so is eating a steak with a spoon
look we both know that there are
things that the spoon is better for and
things that the forks better for i'm
saying in all the instances
i feel like a spork could cover better
in place of a spoon than a spoon can for
a fork
anything that is liquid i can just pour
into my mouth out of the bowl that i'm
eating it from
soup ramen
in some asian countries like thailand
cambodia and laos
spoons and forks are the primary
utensils
laos oh sorry speaking of laos
[Laughter]
they are even used to cut food since
knives have no place at the table unlike
united states it is considered impolite
to put the fork into your mouth
in asian countries well if we have a lot
of asian people voting
i might be bad a spoon i believe is more
of a child's utensil you're not giving a
kid a a dangerous
fork not at least young they're going to
stab themselves in the talk about
in the eyeball a spoon is dull it's for
a child
a fork is a more adult a utensil yes or
no
no but uh but sure whatever you say but
here's the thing
i also like the there's a there's a
versatility with spoons i don't find
with a fork now sure at the table
in a restaurant they'll give you two
forks they'll say one's for your salad
one's for your meal
but spoons i i love the versatility of
the spoon
you got a soup spoon completely
different shape from a tablespoon
completely different shape from a
teaspoon completely different shape
from a serving spoon i think you're
getting the reason you need all those
different size spoons
is that they all perform different
functions because the single spoon
wouldn't necessarily be that universal
with a fork maybe one fork
one size takes care of everything it's
like the swiss army knife of utensils
you need all those different sized
spoons i'll tell you what else is gross
about a fork
it's a barbaric you've got to stab your
food
if you look at a beautiful culture like
asia for instance
you know you look at the beautiful
culture panda of the chinese
chopsticks they lift the food they place
the food in your mouth much like a spoon
does
okay they're not sitting there stabbing
their food
like barbarians because they can't get
it off the plate fast enough
let's take a poll let's take a second
let's take a separate poll let's ask all
of our listeners
when they use forks do they feel like
barbarians no separate polls
that's not how this show works because
that was you do you stab your food when
you eat it or do you just
saying i think it's an interesting thing
that in
in in asian countries it's considered uh
uh
uh grotesque or uh uncouth
to put the fork into your mouth the
stabbing part of the fork the prongs are
it's
primal it's primal you said it not me
it's it's it's it's the selling point of
the fork i'm getting sturdiness i'm
getting dependability
i'm spearing a piece of chicken the
thing that's going in my mouth i could
hold on the fork and i have a
conversation with you
i could have a an animated conversation
with you we could be talking i could be
like
are you kidding me get out of town you
son of a [ __ ] and i pop that right in
my mouth
this whatever i spear is not going
anywhere you pick up a spoon
and you eat and you can you can you
can't get an animated conversation
you're going to be like
i yeah you got to eat like you got to
eat like a human being
you sort of flailing your arms all
around the room and then and then also
the odds that something's falling out of
that spoon
as opposed to something falling off the
spork there's the fork
it's like ten to one let's talk let's
talk to the rim with liquid here
and you gotta bring it to your mouth
there's always that little dance of like
oh god just don't please
let's talk let's rice rice
stock rice one of the great base foods
in all cuisines
yeah and you think you can't pick up
rice with a fork
you can i mean i do it with chopsticks
like two sticks you can it's falling off
nice spoon with some rice are you
kidding me don't bring rice into this
because rice
i mean rice falls right off a chopstick
we're not talking about a chopstick
we're talking about spoons
chopsticks were made for rice
like literally like the rice is eaten
mostly
rice with chopsticks a lot of time you
bring the you bring the bowl to your
mouth and
and and do more of a scooping fashion i
could eat rice with a fork
all day until the cows they come home
you're losing a lot of rice buddy
you're losing a lot of rice are you
insane if you don't have rice
rice if you don't have everything just
sticks together joe when was the last
time every piece of rice in your plate
was separate from the other thing
with the other piece of rice if i
there's a reason there's something
called sticky rice
that's very sticky but rice in general
still compounds about oatmeal
oh i could eat oatmeal with a fork
without a doubt are you still cut
it's thick it's thick it's firm i could
eat i
eat oatmeal with a fork all the time
i eat that troubles fork all the time
well you know you're the one over here
opening with
i'll leave the steak with a spoon i
didn't that's more ridiculous what i
said was
if you had to not if you were not
allowed to have a knife and you're only
given one utensil to eat
a steak with i think you have a better
shot at cutting with the
crazy spoon you are crazy not crazy why
would you
why why would you not agree with me that
if i
took my four prongs on a fork and
sometimes they get fancy into three
prongs
because the price runs don't help you
they're making three separate holes
that's nice i put them in and i and then
i use my my my wrist
to go like this and then i cut the meat
from the inside with the four prongs you
take a spoon
that's a little more oval shaped than
this that is a little more of a point on
the end of it
and you go like this down into the meat
with that
and then this way you're getting you
have so much more circumference on this
all i have to do with the fork though is
go down from the side that's how i cut
every single piece of food i rarely pick
up a fork i mean uh a knife as a matter
of fact
because rarely i do because i find that
the fork i can cut
most things with the fork most really
yeah i just put a little little wrist
grease into it okay
all right and i slice right through
whatever i need okay all right well
you know i i don't know what to tell you
that sounds like a lunatic
to talking but you know there's a knife
there for a reason
but that's besides the point what about
okay french onion soup
fork i don't think so pal yeah
you're crazy red gruyere cheese onions
all on the fork
rest sip from the bowl the bowl in
itself is a big spoon
without a handle you understand that
right all the spoon is
is a small bowl with a handle on the end
of it okay
so i could throw the spoon out because
anything that's served in a bowl i don't
need any utensils for it
but you need a fork you need it
for certain foods you can't do it with a
spoon you don't need it
a nice big leafy salad you're not having
a good time with a spoon there
so what is the different here's the
thing if you can go anything
you can go barbaric enough you're gonna
eat it hold on if you can go barbaric
enough to say
well with soup i'll just pick up the
bowl and slurp it out
that's not that why can't i say well
with salad i'll get what i can with the
spoon and then just pick up the rest of
my hands i would be cursing at the end
of a meal if i had to eat a big bowl of
salad with a spoon i would really
probably at the end of it right away
you're not answering my question the the
the
you're bringing a second utensil into
the mix with your soup argument you're
saying
i'll use the fork for as far as i can
get and then
i'll just pick up the bowl and drink it
what i'm saying is
well by that logic i'll just eat what i
can with the salad with the spoon
and then i'll just pick up the plate and
and slide it into my mouth or whatever
no
joe that's not the same thing the reason
for it is because i can spear anything
that the fork will have out of the bowl
of soup
when it's done with just broth the bowl
is the perfect receptacle
that fits my mouth to a tea that is
designed for me to drink it out
and i will have that bowl completely
empty with no issues
if you're trying to scoop out a salad
just with a spoon
you're not going to get as much as you
can and then turn the plate sideways
and have all the roughage come shooting
down into your gullet it's going to be a
big mess you can't do the same thing
it's not apples to apples
then what's the difference if i say i
use my hands what's the difference
you called lifting a bowl to your mouth
and sipping out of it barbados i got to
tell you something but you're
no it is barbaric i'm bringing one
barbaric thing to meet another
i think people picking up a bowl and
slurping out of it
is gross and unmannerly and if i saw
somebody do it at a restaurant
i would think certain things of that
person
okay but you're talking about a world
where all utensils exist
and are used and we're talking about
what is the better utensil
and i'm just saying that i'm not saying
that i'm going to go to a restaurant and
choose not to use a spoon just because
but i'm saying if i can use one for the
rest of my life i'm going to choose this
desert island all you got to eat is
coconuts
wha what are we doing that we're always
finding ourselves on them
desert island all you got to eat is
coconuts
you know it fork you're nuts how you
opening that how you opening the coconut
on a rock like tom hanks and castaway
and then i'm gonna scoop things out with
a spoon in fact i believe tom hanks
fashioned himself
a spoon for the coconuts and castor
unclear all i'm saying is anything you
could scoop out of a coconut with a
spoon i could scoop out of a coconut
with a fork
as a matter of fact i think the prongs
of a fork will serve me better
in the world no you can't you're you are
discounting
the use of the edge of the spoon the
shape of the spoon and why
i think you're overselling the shape of
the snow i'm telling you
let's talk bare bottom folks i'll tell
you what i got two bags of stuff that i
ordered here and
i have been wearing i i've almost worn
everything
in like the two weeks straight that i've
had it yeah because
it's like that beautiful medium ground
between like
dressing up and like also just like
being able to just go anywhere with it i
love something that's a
cause because i'm a single man oh you
need a versatile piece of garment
exactly because you don't want to show
up on a date going i'm trying too hard
or
hey lady i don't care right neither of
you want to show up where she goes
he's just right we're talking the third
ball porridge babe yeah
you want to go from the gym where you're
bench pressing all sorts of pounds
that's right and you want to be able to
skirt right over there to lunch at a
nice outdoor cafe where you zip your
coffee this is what i'm saying and i
love
bare bottom slacks i said it before i'll
say it again
internet's best deal is coming from
these guys just got so spam bottom
slangs
boots with the first they got the best
deal on high quality and versatile
menswear plus they got ten thousand
five star reviews which doesn't hurt uh
and i like that they're giving back
too that's part of what the company does
bare bottom has donated over
a hundred thousand pairs of shorts to
children in need
and they're going to start this summer
with uh donating a school lunch for each
item
why doesn't every clothing company do
that can we all do that
we should all i mean why do they have to
be i mean bare bottom is the only people
doing this yeah so support bare bottom
right now our listeners get free
shipping off their first order of these
super comfortable threads where they
gotta go joe where they gotta go
barebottomclothing.com
use that promo code tastebuds that's
barebottomclothing.com
spelled b-e-a-r like the animal bottom
clothing.com and use the promo code
tastebuds
get yourself some free shipping dude i
swear to god you know me
well you know my favorite stuff i'm
truffles all the way
i got we got a package in the mail
because our new sponsor is
truff the brand truff yes it was very
exciting i tore that open like it was
nobody's business it was very exciting
i have the full trough product line i
have been eating
truffle infused ever hot the first of
all is the hot sauce
which is unbelievable then it's the
hotter sauce which is cool then there's
a mayo and there's a hot mayo yeah and a
truffle
truffle oil and then there's also the
white truffle one usually it's like
black truffle but they have the white
truffle too
very cool i didn't i like i keep hearing
about it out of
nowhere now and i looked it up two dudes
yeah
did it out of the garage yeah they just
tested hundreds of sauces out of like
their family's garage
i think that's so cool and and they uh
landed on trough
which they described as a luxurious hot
sauce infused with black truffle
uh hot sauce is all the rage right now
like i've been seeing it like everything
i mean you know
obviously you got all the shows on
television now using i don't know
overall to mention them but
hot sauce is is having a like a
revolution a renaissance right now
so this is a luxury hot sauce brand it's
inspired by elegance and indulgence of
truffles obviously
uh i like truff it's like a luxury sort
of hot sauce brand
uh and you know it's look it's it's it's
based in truffle so obviously
black truffles there's chilis there's
like all sorts of spices yeah i think
agave yeah and what i think is cool
about it is is
uh it's it's something that you could
it's a hot sauce that you can put on
certain dishes and it's gonna really pop
with the certain things that you blend
it with i like that i like that it's
it it almost functions like a wine i was
like hot sauce
i keep hearing about it and then we were
gonna i put it in when i was ordering
like amazon like
my whole foods right and it's the number
one on there so i guess it's having a
real big explosion yeah
so we got an offer for you you can get
15 off
site wide meaning whatever you get all
the products because they
they don't just have the hot sauce the
hot sauce is dope yeah but they have
everything
if i could have all truffle everything
every day i would
so this i think that's a little crazy no
not for me no
i said it i speak my own truth okay i
almost think you need to talk to
somebody about that no
but i but i do love truff uh get 15
off site wide plus free shipping when
you use promo code tastebuds
at truff.com that's get 15 off site-wide
plus free shipping with promo code
tastebuds
at truff.com that's truff.com
15 off everything at trough t-r-u-f-f
f is for fantastic dot com using that
promo code
taste buds you can't do this with a fork
and the bottom of the ben and jerry's
tub
you can't get in there with a fork like
you can with you know you can
if i'm only carrying one thing on me i'm
carrying a fork
that's it all right i mean also if i had
to go to battle
i told you i really do i don't want to
discount the fork as a weapon
oh dude they'll give you a spoon in
battle before they give you a fork how
so
i i will stab you with a fork
immediately
what are you going to do with a spoon
what are you doing a man was executed
tuesday for fatally stabbing a prison
guard with a sharpened spoon
shank shank well on death row for that
he had to sharpen it
say say what's the pull out a tablespoon
i want you to i want you to type these
exact words well you can pick the bowl
up to your mouth i can sharpen my spoon
you could put murder with a spoon murder
with a fork murder with a spark
with a knife what is this gonna come up
exactly like this
pimp what is the one utensil they give
you in the army
just just put that i want to see what
comes up
why do they give you only one utensil
because sometimes you only get look at
that
they give you a splade or
a spore which is a combination of a fork
knife and spoon
well once again spoon takes precedence
splayed
starts with spoons sporks it starts with
spoon
spoon is where it all because look at
that that thing's awesome
wow and that's what i'm talking about
where's the knife
it's on the end it's on the side wow
well you can't
that doesn't come into the oven i'm
saying it's all three utensils in one
now
it comes into the argument and you see
the indentation in the back of the fork
that's that proves you can't just eat
anything with a fork
you need an indentation you need prawns
i don't know i don't think you need the
prongs all the time to be honest
i'm trying to think of a food where i
need prongs
salad was a great one spoons are used
primarily for eating liquid or
semi-liquid foods such as soup
stew they showed 15 different species
ice cream and very small
powdery salad items which cannot be
easily lifted with a fork
such as rice sugar cereals and
green pea ooh greens oh i eat my peas i
eat my peas with a fork
that's i eat my peas with a fork all the
time
only eat peas with a fork inside so that
could take a walk in southeast asia
spoons are the primary
used tencel used for eating forks are
used to push food
such as rice onto the spoon right but
they have a different
culture and a different they do things
differently out there that doesn't mean
to me
that fork is not gonna win here i mean
they eat with chopsticks
seinfeld has that great bit i've
mentioned it on here already tell you
what he's like you gotta
i gotta handle the chinese people
they're really hanging in there with the
chopsticks you think you're going to
make no they've seen the phone you think
you're going to
you think you're going to make a nice
peanut butter and jelly with a fork i
have
i have no you have i do whatever i need
to do i do too i do too i scoop it out
you haven't
i have i'm telling you i have i'm not
sitting here
i didn't show up to launch why would you
today why would you do that when i do
this to prepare
when do you need to do that i don't know
i'll give you an example let's say like
there were only plastic utensils
wherever i was if it was outdoors
barbecue whatever and i was making
a sandwich and and there was no forks so
you have no knives let me get this
straight
you're in an outdoor function all i'm
telling you is that they have a
peanut butter and jelly bar and they
have spoons available and for
a function of the peanut butter to use a
fork
instead of a spoon no joe all i'm
telling you is i
and if you and if you want to challenge
me i'll go downstairs right now
i'll get bread peanut butter and jelly
and a fork only i'll come up i'll make
the sandwich in front of you
with ease and then i'll eat it and i
will just put you to shame
i'll tell you what i want your ass
downstairs right now don't don't get a
jar of peanut butter
get a shout out sour took a peanut
butter get two pieces of bread
i mean i'm gonna make the sandwich show
i'm gonna make it too i'm just gonna
from the back side of the fork
i'm gonna scoop the peanut butter and
i'm gonna use it tangled like a spoon no
worries
it's just the jelly there's no words
like that oh words just jelly scoops
right out right here and you know what's
gonna help
my prongs on the fork are gonna slice
through the jelly and in a way that
breaks it down and makes it more
spreadable right here
show me this your spoon is just gonna
push jelly to the corners
i mean i don't know why we're talking
about it let's see it in action i'm
sitting here
go ahead but what is this going to prove
it's going to prove that the spoon is
much better so when i
when i come upstairs right now with two
pieces of bread peanut butter and jelly
in the fork and i make a peanut butter
sandwich in front of you which i'm about
to do
you're going to make a [ __ ] peanut
butter and jelly sandwich i'm going to
make it very simply and then what
happens if i want to see
how i want to see how simply you make it
i don't believe you
i don't believe you can make a nice
peanut butter and jelly with a fork
but i'm going to make the sandwich joe
you'll make the sandwich and then we'll
you'll make the sauce where do we stand
when i think our fans would like to see
this this this technique that you have
that's going to make such a beautiful
peanut butter
let me talk to you you don't think that
you can make a peanut butter jelly with
a fork oh you can
make one well that is going to be [ __ ]
it's going to be a messy you don't think
that i could pull it together
and just spread the peanut butter evenly
on a slice of bread with it oh you think
i'm going to get up here and be like
whoa and everything's just going to go
flying all over the place
who am i the sweetest chef i'm sitting
here waiting to see you do it
oh my god
[Music]
then two slices of bread we'll each do
our own utensil
we're gonna just make two sandwiches
we're gonna just
do it what is the problem i think you
can't make one with a spoon
so what is the point of you making
because you're talking like you can whip
this thing together with a fork and it's
gonna look fine and it's not
here's what i'm telling you pally i'm
gonna go get it right now and i'm gonna
talk on the mic if you're gonna talk
talk on the mic i walked away
you know i walked away listen i'm gonna
go get it i'm gonna make it in front of
you and all you're gonna do is you're
gonna try and harp
on any little thing i'm not i want to
see you with ease as you said with these
put this together swear to christ go
ahead and wait
[Laughter]
this is a first another first year taste
buds
we're actually going to see it happen in
action
going down to the kitchen to get a fork
some peanut butter some jelly two pieces
of bread
we're each gonna make a one-sided
sandwich peanut butter and jelly i will
only be using
my fork my spoon
he's gonna come up and use his fork now
before he returns as i said do i think
it's possible
of course it is i saw a guy once cook a
steak on a car motor
anything is possible is it gonna be
good is the question that's the question
here he comes back in folks the man of
the hour
did you get two pieces of bread yeah all
right all right i'm just making sure you
know
what world's am i getting one piece of
bread well because you got to use one
and i got to use one i would have used
the taste buds signature peanut butter
but
it's so delicious i talk to talk i walk
the walk i just wanna let you know
there's nothing left
all right so i love it i'm gonna use
a creamy no stir what the hell kind of
bread is this
this is fresh break stone ground
sourdough bread from balthazar
all right yeah it's real great bread and
you tried to trash it
but immediately you saw the era of your
way this is like you just defrosted a
loaf of italian bread well i kept i keep
my bread in the fridge all right all
right
i keep i can't well certain bread i keep
in the fridge what are you doing why are
you taking it you go one side i go the
other side wouldn't bring a spoon i make
it a sandwich i've got a spoon
you put your peanut butter on yours with
your fork i'll put mine on with a spoon
you know how
easy this is going to be show me baby so
you have to show me babe so you
stop talking and start showing but i
thought the problem was you think that i
can't make this
i think i never told you that you can't
make all of this no i just want to see
how drastically better it looks with the
spoon
ready yeah go ahead here we go
there it is nice and easy
okay there's that part of it okay
i mean that's evenly sprayed don't don't
close that yet now we got to show how
the paper goes
you want to get a shot of how evenly
spread that was in maybe i don't know
maybe three seconds maybe let's go
see that let's go oh it's got lines hold
on a second
slow down champ i got to do this because
i don't want to put i don't want to
double dip i don't want to lick it and
put it back in that
i'm considering okay so i'm wiping the
peanut butter
hold on and wipe that off with that look
at that
he's taking longer than i did look at
that with hello fresh let's talk hello
fresh
let's talk i want to talk about hello
hello
fresh knock knock who is it
fresh fresh who hello
you did not do that right i don't even
know what just happened i did my
look hello friends talk hellofresh
though you're gonna get your fresh
pre-mesh ingredients and mouth-watering
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
front door
people are complaining all the time i
don't have time to cook the delivery
apps are too expensive
why do i got to pay a delivery fee i
don't like fast food
guys here is your chance to get quality
meals brought to your house
they're going to lay it out for you
paint by number style
and you're going to be able to cook in
30 minutes or less
i'm talking cooking to the table 30
minutes or less
for all meals three meals a day plus
snacks and special treats in between
um 28 uh cheaper than shopping at a
local grocery store 72 cheaper than a
restaurant i'm just saying
i am all about the convenience and if
you want to start to learn
if you don't cook normally one thing i
don't like too is like following a
recipe if i go to the
supermarket i'm like what do i got to do
i love that it's just it's there
they've got a vibe do it wide variety of
artisan
style meals delicious foods whatever
it's coming right to your door it could
not be easier to make stuff for yourself
it will be
literally faster than if you went to get
fast food and then drove home who wants
to come home from work
and have to worry about making those
choices so go to hellofresh.com
tastebuds 12 hellofresh.com
tastebuds 1-2 and then
use the promo code tastebuds12
for 12 free meals best deal out there i
know you're looking at me
oh i'm free shipping you're looking at
us going why taste buds 12
why not just taste buds that'd be easier
because you're getting 12
free meals plus free shipping when was
the last time someone but your mama gave
you 12 free meals
that's that that was my copy but it was
great honestly hello fresh if you want
to use it
you use it no no one to end it that was
beautiful
all right ready guys you want to talk to
you about buffy buffet
buffy makes betting that it's earth
friendly and cruelty free
and that is at the top of a lot of
people's lists these days we've spent
sleepless nights worrying about the
impact of the betting industry
has on the environment buffy did and so
they decided to change it their products
are made using only sustainable and
recycled materials
which makes them as soft on the planet
as they are on your bed
and this is true uh i have the buffy
breeze
uh comforter i'm waiting for them i have
tried
over and over with so many different
comforters to get something that
alleviates my night sweats i'm always
hot when i sleep
uh but then also wasn't something that
was weighted or this or that
it's perfect you feel comforted you feel
coddled you're
under a nice comforter yet you're cool
and feeling good and not sweating it's a
hundred percent plant-based design and
it's breathable
it's made of eucalyptus fabric yeah
inside and out is it that's softer than
cotton yeah uh it soothes the skin
naturally
hypoallergenic that's a big one yeah
that's huge that's huge because the
goose down sometimes will get you
sneezing there is no down in it no um
it's a free trial you can try the
comforter in your own bed and if you
don't love it
uh you can return it um
so for twenty dollars off your buffy
comforter
go to buffy.co buffy.cobuffy.co
and enter tastebuds be you ffy.co and
enter tastebuds you're gonna get 20
bucks off
a sweet buffy comforter taking longer
than i did
okay now here's your scoop jelly
because this idiot here thinks that i
can't do it there's nothing
i'm already done i'm already done i just
made a peanut butter and jelly
it's evenly spread it took me no it
didn't zero mess
it took me no time whatsoever
how peanut butter jelly's eating how
dare you say that's evenly spread how
dare you
you're kidding me right no that looks
like somebody got shot in the head and
that's what hit the wall afterwards
where is it where is it lacking the
jelly where where here
here here okay hold on
okay okay look at that big piece of
brain right there
oh you're reaching joe you're itching
look at this
wait now i gotta spread my jelly but joe
what happened what happened i gotta
spread my jelly now
okay what does that prove again i never
told you you can't make it with a spoon
and again i son of a [ __ ] and again i
told you
stop it stop it i told you
that it's going to be better with a
spoon
how's it going how the [ __ ] it going
to be better it's the same three
ingredients done in
the same exact way that is
way too much jelly that's going to shoot
out
that is so much jelly this has proved my
point
this proved my point you're overdoing it
i've never seen
that much you got to zoom in i need them
to i need to i need a little
listeners to weigh in on this i need the
viewers to weigh in on this that is so
much
jelly oh it's way over the top looks
pretty good to me
you can't fold that i know what you're
going to do you're going to pull some
[ __ ] where you have an open-faced
peanut butter and juice
i can't fold it joe do not get it on my
carpet
you think i can't fold it i think you
cannot not without now without shooting
on the sides here okay
right over there good hold it and now
take bites out of it
get take a bite out look at this pip
zoom in pimp
zoom in because this guy's failing at it
with the spoon and i wasn't even
challenging him with this
hold on a second why he said mine was
going to be a mess
he said look at the truth
since when is it bad to have how much
jelly is left on his spoon pip
look at this look he has so much look at
the jelly in the middle of the look at
that
look at that and look at how much he has
on his shimmer look at his fingers
look at him you just touch my sandwich
you failed so bad
i didn't fail that's how i make a peanut
butter and jelly joe
joe i don't know if you heard everything
you said was gonna happen to me i don't
know if you heard
i have a sandwich shop dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
zoom in yeah okay
i'm so happy it's all over your face i
love it
joe this is a failure view don't look at
me in the eye and say this isn't a
failure for you oh you
everything you said that was gonna
happen to me with the fork happened to
you with the spoon
it's messy it's all over the place i
made it better than you more efficiently
than you
quicker than you i knew this was gonna
happen i shed it
rewind the tape i said a few things i
said
i said what do you think is gonna happen
i'm gonna come up here i'm gonna make a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich with a
fork
simply and easily and i'm gonna eat it
and then what are you gonna say he
didn't say anything and that's exactly
what happened
i also said i don't even think you can't
make it with a spoon there's no reason
for you to even make one
you made one anyway and then you dug a
hole for yourself because you couldn't
even pull it off
with ease and precision right you really
took a real real hot chicken mine's
delicious
can you not even over mine don't eat
over mine i want it because i still want
to eat it look at the amount of
jelly i put a lot of jelly still on the
spoon there was never a rule about it
was even spread was the argument and it
was even literally
your jellies all over the side of the
plate here here on your fingers your
lips
coming out of the side of it you talked
about brain stuff this looks like
explosive
brain matter got to stop touching it you
can't waste jelly like that
i wasn't raised like that wasted you put
what you need on it you're going to
eat that jelly wasting jelly you have
spoonfuls of jelly to eat onions
spoonfuls he says let's go to the phones
you're gonna eat that jelly alkart
i swear to god remember when you had to
wipe your spoon off
pump whole sandwich i ate
zero zero mess zero even because you
barely put any peanut butter or jelly on
it
oh this guy
this guy forget about it now forget it
start reading comments
please yeah i know you're doing what
you're wrong you go to the phones when
you fail
you want to go to the phones right away
yeah
yeah that's what's happening
damn good sandwich which one
well you didn't even bring up magic
spoon i literally see 15 inches of
magical heads in this podcast
you can't use a fork with cereal if you
chose fork you also anti-magic spoon
already i need another napkin
i don't wanna get the mic dirty at all
um
guys you can scoop anything with a spoon
not true
anything that you need a spoon for can
be dumped directly
into your hole that's what i said that's
what i said just dump it in your
don't say that's not true that's true
you can eat anything with a fork except
soup i guess but soup isn't really even
a meal anyway
look at this look at this guy he's still
having trouble i'm i've digested my
sandwich
he's he has the shakes
[Laughter]
look what happened the jelly fell out
into his bomb look get it on camera
own it own it
oh this took up this just just took a
turn on you
you look like a preschooler right now
look at you look at you
both hands are in the air you can't even
hold the plate because your hands are
filthy the plate is filthy
you got jelly all over the goddamn
coffee table with a spoon
chunks of jelly oh you
you son of a [ __ ] you're a son of a
[ __ ]
i mean this just felt the wheels fell
off the wheels fell off of your spoon
look at this look at this it's
disgusting what he did
oh it's uh i mean i mean i rest my
i don't need i should not have to say
another word
i shouldn't have to say another word i
didn't even challenge him to use a spoon
to compare i just said i'll come up i'll
make it simply and i'll do it i did what
i said
and everything that he was trying to do
went wrong and he was trying to show me
up with it
and it all went wrong would you just
wipe that off with a dry rag
what are you a barbarian you don't think
the jelly residue is all over that
that countertop i was scooping it up
with a tissue because it was all i could
find right now
well what a mess the spoon made yeah
i like a messy sandwich
you know what's gonna happen you're
gonna get jumped on the streets you're
gonna get jumped on the streets i swear
to you
i i swear to you someone's gonna just
see you
and they're gonna clock you in the chops
and say i'm sorry but i had to do that
for all the disrespect
uh another contender for best comment
today spoon is so versatile you can use
it for everything the best thing about a
fork is shoving it into an outlet
shoving the fork the fork can you eat
soup with a fork
no you cannot how are you gonna eat your
liquids when you're an old man not only
that but
one wrong move the fork ends your life
babe just saying i'm telling you right
now i think the weapon the fork as a
weapon is a
is a plus and also guys the soup
argument is old guys
i i it's done we just sip the soup out
of the bowl
so i love all you got is soup
and that's not even and i'm dispelling
the soup uh argument
okay i say spoon because it's better to
eat with i mostly use spoons then i use
forks
uh spooning leads to forking very clever
uh this again when you get spoon a
sponsor called magic fork
oh they're coming out see our fans are
coming out of the image wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait go back
i used a fork i used a fork to stab my
brother in the forehead when we were
young
let four dots in his head so forks look
i i brought up the weaponizing of the
fork the spoon can do the job of a fork
but a fork can't do the job of a spoon
not true ah next person said right to
you i'd argue the opposite is true
forks scoop better than spoon stab
jeremy
100 correct
forks you need to stab with precisions
spoons you just need to be in the
general area
plus you can't really shovel with a fork
oh i shovel
there's room for human error out of
laziness and pure gluttony i vote spoons
the fact
that's okay oh this one undispute
actually beep that i'm not giving them a
promo uh
an account here says we just running out
of ideas here no absolutely not we're
having fun and innovating you piece of
[ __ ]
yeah go to that podcast page real quick
all right all right leave it alone sorry
sorry
strong disagree salad with a spoon is a
nightmare oh wait somebody brought up
salad with a spoon of course they did
because it was a very good argument that
i made
they weren't listening to yourself no
but i'm so it's a relatable
universal truth
how about this here's scroll up a little
bit spoon shouldn't exist
simple as that feels like a ufo in your
mouth
they're only good for soup and cereal
and that's about it might as well use a
ladle
a spork is better than a spoon utensils
sanity is as follows
fork spoon fork spork spoon this is
interesting here's a cadet
uh this is a military argument if my
cadet days are anything to go by i'd say
i wouldn't be too fussed if i forgot a
fork
but pissed if i forgot a spoon they're
just more handy to have
thank you spoon because of ice cream
spoon
heads right and even numbers are the
same forks tails left and odd numbers oh
okay i will tell you this babe we both
thought we were the reason we picked out
of a hat is we both
thought fork and from the comments seem
to be skewing more spoon no
no i think it's pretty even i think
we're just let's go to the vote pimp
we're about out of time here uh that was
what i said too spoon you got to balance
everything
fork i don't know where it was but
actually neither
the greatest kitchen utensil was a large
purple spatula
if i get okay our winner let's give the
win to the first magic spoon
comment that was very funny are you
ready for this
i don't know which way it's going to be
i don't know either i i was confident
very very confident follow joe what's
his name wait pimp slot on the trigger
there
follow joe louis at plaque or
plaque p l a q u e
o r p l a c k let's get this humble pie
segment in here drum roll please
10 816 votes
oh i'll take it
62.2 fork to 37.8
spoon that is a decent that's nearing a
12
margin of victory which is where i
thought we'd land which is where i
thought we'd land
all right i'll take that i'll take that
write to us at info
tastebudspod.com and leave us
merch that you would like do you want it
on a hat
we got hats hoodies and t-shirts covered
tell me where else you want you want
socks
you want uh under garments
do you want uh you want forks and spoons
what do you want
tell us what you want tell us what you
wanted to say tell us what you like tell
us what you
you you you parrot and and and and say
most when you think of it and you
you're talking with your friends and you
guys are all talking about your favorite
episodes of taste buds and who said what
and all this was a real zinger when
you're
laughing and you're pushing each other
into the bushes tell us what you talk
about we'll put it on
on some merch for you that's info taste
buds
pod.com i still love you babe i love you
too
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste buds